all right let's give this a shot we're
gonna try the phones for the first time
from the new studio six one seven eight
three zero 4750 could be a disaster
hopefully the phone system has been
configured correctly and if so we should
be able to hear very soon
from our caller in the six four six area
code caller from six four six can you
hear me and most importantly can we hear
you I can hear you very well can you
hear me we can go ahead who's this
what's on your mind great my name is
Mary and congratulations on the new
studio oh thank you and and I do have a
question for you so I have a little show
and I listen to you and Tom Hartman and
others you know Sam cedar etc I'd like
your take on infantryman Dixon is
fantastic as well I would like your take
on sort of there's a little bit of a
toilet with this a split on the left
regarding identity politics yes and
given what's happening now we are not in
people kind of want to stay stuck in the
2016 primary and I I've been saying I'm
not sure I've had journalists I'm if I
candidates across the country I we can't
say stop in the 2016 primary that's not
where we are now I've been saying you
know we have to look at what's happening
now and I will just like your thoughts I
don't even this thing to bendixson or
you just sort of lose a little bit of
fighting going that you know regarding
identity politics versus Lykes a class
you know a class to talk about class
first or you know identity politics is
also who's been fighting with I'm not up
to speed on that it's not about fighting
it's just actors to spend a little bit
of a infighting or a little bit about
how it is on the left we're like herding
cats right yeah politics I didn't know
if Ben was involved in a specific thing
so here's somebody I um in all five
members great I do
I got you Mary by the way if we are on
speakerphone or Bluetooth please do take
us off because we're having a hard time
hearing you so listen here's my thought
on the identity politics thing number
one the split is actually not nearly as
big as the right would like you to
believe the
the people on the Left who are miss
handling identity politics are actually
not that significant but there are
people who are miss handling it so what
is the right approach right on identity
politics versus race and whatever else
number one identity relates I'm sorry in
class not race identity relates to class
in really important ways in the United
States that's number one so the debate
over identity versus class is not really
a total black and white thing the way
some would make you believe that's
number one identity is how you exist in
the world so if anyone wants to pretend
that identity is irrelevant for the
political world for figuring out what
humans should be doing on the planet
identity matters and identity is
important where you go over the line is
where identity becomes a trump card
to decide who gets to speak who should
be listen to what the only ways of
thinking about an issue should be so
identity politics when done wrong is a
problem it's not as big of an issue as
the right wants you to believe it is on
the left and we should understand that
people's identity gives them a
perspective on issues that is important
and it is relevant and it should be
listened to it's just not a trump card
that's it it's actually a much simpler
issue than many are making it out to be
well thank you so much you always bring
clarity to an issue thank you so much
thank you great to hear from you good to
hear that the phone system is working at
the new studio